a big thank you to oliver dowden who's
uh who's just resigned he's been an
excellent party chairman it was a very
good culture secretary did a lot of
good with broadband rollout to set up
the office for veterans affairs
and yes it's absolutely true that
we've had some some tough by-election
results and
they've been i think
a reflection of a lot of things but
we've got to recognize that
voters are going through a tough time at
the moment and i think that as a
government
i've got to listen to what people are
saying
and in particular to the difficulties
people are facing over the cost of
living
which is i think for most people the the
number one issue
and there what we're doing is as much as
we can to help people 1200 pounds for
the 8 million most vulnerable households
help for everybody with the cost of of
heating trying to cut taxes uh where we
can
but what i can say to people is we will
get through this we will get through it
well uh but clearly we've got to listen
from uh listen to these results well
oliver dalton says you can't go on with
business as usual and everything you
just said is what you've been saying for
weeks this is about you it's not about
all the other stuff well that that that
may be uh your view i think that uh what
governments have also got to recognize
is that
uh although you know i don't want to in
any way to minimize
the importance of what voters are saying
it is also true that in
mid-term uh governments post-war uh lose
by-elections i think that if you look
back to last may the truly astonishing
thing was we managed to win hartley paul
in in in very different uh circumstances
what we need to do now is reflect on
where voters are and what they're i
think what they're basically feeling is
that you know we came through covered
well we took a lot of the right
decisions there but when i facing
pressures on the costs of living we're
seeing uh spikes in in fuel prices uh
energy costs uh food costs that that's
hitting people we've got to under we've
got to we've got to recognize that there
is more that we've
got to do and we certainly will we will
keep going addressing the concerns of
people until we get through this patch
doesn't this tell you that you were not
as you said vindicated by the sugray
report people are very angry and they
voted to get you out people voted
tactically
to defeat the conservative party look as
i say you you see uh historically in the
last
50 years more
you've seen governments
being
punished at the polls uh during midterm
uh when people are particularly feeling
uh economic pressures and i i totally
get that i think that what we've got is
the right way forward and i think that
actually we are able to support people
because of the
decisions that we took i think
we've coming out of kobe we took a lot
of the right decisions but plainly we've
got to keep looking after people making
sure that we have a robust strongly
performing economy as it happens we've
got
unemployment uh very low by historic
standards we've got a lot more people in
work
than we had before the pandemic began
those that's a good background that's a
good basis
on which to to build and that's what
we're gonna do um you're meeting prince
charles today there's been no denial
from his office that he's appalled by
your rwanda
policy if he tells you he thinks it's
important what are you gonna say
i wouldn't comment on anything that uh
i say to or the
queen or the queen says to me or nor
would i say anything about what the
throne might say to me or what i might
say uh to to him and that that's never
happened the prime minister's never
talked about that and quite rightly but
what i will say is i think people coming
to rwanda as you have uh today christian
everybody else has in the in this in
this group i think people can see that a
lot of prejudices about arawanda need to
be blown away and actually the uh the
achievements of the government of rwanda
over the last couple of decades have
been very remarkable
and i think that the
the
migration and economic development
partnership we've got is a creative
attempt to solve a problem that affects
countries around the world so we're
building a partnership between the uk
and rwanda to address something that is
frankly evil uh people uh taking people
across the the channel in unseaworthy
vessels and we've come up with a plan to
fix it uh
no uk court has so far ruled it unlawful
we're gonna stick with it